[موسيقى]
ما يجب ان نعرفه عن الانتخابات النصفيه في
امريكا كما تعلمون انتخابات الرئاسه
الامريكيه تجرى كل اربع سنوات وهذا
الاختيار رئيس للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الانتخابات النصفيه هي تجرى كل سنتين
وسميت نصفيه لانها تاتي في منتصفه ولايه
الرئيس
لماذا هي مهمه الانتخابات النصفيه ولانها
في منتصف ولايه الرئيس فهي بمثابه استفتاء
حقيقي على مدى رضا الامريكيين عن اداء
رئيسهم واذا كانوا يرغبون في تعطيل
قراراته بانتخاب اغلبيه في الكونجرس من
الحزب الاخر
يتعلق الامر كله بمن يسيطر على هذا المبنى
الكونجرس يعود الامر الى عام
1787 عندما قرر واضع الدستور الامريكي ان
البرلمان سيكون من غرفتين وهذا ما حصلوا
عليه
الكونجرس يتكون من غرفتين مجلس النواب ب
435 مقعدا وتبقا للماده الاولى من الدستور
الامريكي ينتخب اعضاء مجلس النواب كل
سنتين اما مجلس الشيوخ الذي يضم 100 مقعد
ينتخب الشيوخ فيها كل ست سنوات
[موسيقى]
السباق في الانتخابات النصفيه بين الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري يكون على
435 مقعدا في مجلس النواب اي كامل المجلس
وخمسه وثلاثين مقعدا من مجلس الشيوخ اي
ثلث اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الذي يضم 100 مقعد
كذلك ينتخب الامريكيون في هذا الثامن من
نوفمبر اعضاء المجالس المحليه وحكام 36
ولايه من اصل 50 ولايه امريكيه
الوضع الحالي الديمقراطيون لديهم اغلبيه
ضئيله في مجلس النواب منذ عام
1934 فاز حزب الرئيس باغلبيه مجلس النواب
في الانتخابات النصفيه ثلاث مرات فقط اما
مجلس الشيوخ فهو منقسم بخمسين مقعدا لكل
الحزبين وسيجري التنافس على 34 مقعدا منها
في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
منذ العام
1934 فاز حزب الرئيس 6 مرات باغلبيه مجلس
الشيوخ وفي مره واحده فقط لم يحصل تغير
للاغلبيه في المسجد